well with all the screeching recently
about Vladimir Putin in Russia and
treason it's been easy to miss the real
news we have some real news the United
States is inching closer apparently to
some kind of conflict with Iran this
Sunday the president tweeted this quote
to Iranian president rouhani never ever
threaten the United States again or you
will suffer the consequences the likes
of which few throughout history have
ever suffered before we're no longer a
country that will stand for your
demented words of violence and death be
cautious exclamation point well the
interesting thing about this tweet is
what didn't happen the first is usually
quick to jump on the president's in
temperate tweets seenin has apparently
an entire team of progressive teenagers
devoted to monitoring his feed but this
time there wasn't much comment from the
media why because if there's one thing
Washington loves more than open borders
and fat lobbying contracts
it's pointless Wars half a world away
contractors get rich neocon
intellectuals feel powerful bill kristol
max boot and Nancy Pelosi agree on one
thing war is good as long as the war
does not help the United States John
Bolton finds himself in this that camp a
lifelong neocon Bolton repeatedly has
called for toppling the Iranian
government again and again though
tellingly he's never suggested what
might replace the iranian government
once it's toppled now these National
Security Adviser he has been changing
our policies the US for example has
begun promoting protests within Iran in
an effort to overthrow the regime their
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo appears
to be on board with this UN Ambassador
nikki Haley definitely is here's a
recent sampling of her saber rattling on
Iran watch their government has a long
history of murdering its own people who
dare to speak the truth the Iranian
regime is now on notice the world will
be watching what you do if you want to
come to the table and work on a new Iran
deal we'll be right there to talk to you
but you're not going to threaten us to
do it Iran may have messed with the
wrong president here absolutely did now
some of that is bluster obviously but
some of it is exactly what it looks like
the groundwork for conflict we are
moving toward however slowly some kind
of confrontation with Iran
now that should worry everybody but it
should especially
be of concern to anyone who supported
the president if President Trump decides
to go to war with Iran it will destroy
his presidency just as the Iraq war
destroyed the presidency of his
Republican predecessor George W Bush
attacking Iran is not like intervening
in Libya or Syria or even like invading
Iraq it entails far greater risk and
much higher costs geographically Iran is
about four times the size of Iraq it has
three times as many people as Iraq had
when we invaded Iraq was a divided
country along religious lines Iran is
not its cohesive it's a much richer
country too with a military that has
spent many years preparing for a u.s.
invasion it's a formidable force in 2002
the US military carried out a war game
that was widely understood to be a
simulation of an invasion of Iran it
went badly America suffered more than
20,000 casualties in a single day and
officials halted the game so the
question is not could America beat Iran
yes it could the question is is it ready
to try well less ready than ever
actually compared to 2003 our country is
deeper in debt and former politically
divided than it's been since the Civil
War our military is overstretched ask
anyone in it meanwhile China is much
stronger than it was 15 years ago you
can bet the Chinese military will be
more assertive than ever when we're tied
down and yet another quagmire does
anyone outside of Washington actually
support a new war in Iran well the Saudi
royal family does so the leaders of
other Sunni Gulf states they see Iran as
their greatest rival and they'd love to
have America fight a war against Iran
for them why wouldn't they president
Trump's own supporters know better than
this though you'll remember that back in
2016 during the Republican primary
debate in South Carolina Donald Trump
was the only person on that stage to
call the Iraq war a mistake he vowed
never to repeat anything like that and
promised that if elected he would act
only in America's interests now the
morons handicapping the debate on
television predicted Trump would lose it
was over saying that had sealed his fate
and of course they were wrong and he won
Republican voters agreed with him it
turned out they had a better sense of
the truth a lot of their kids were
serving in the military two and a half
years later amazingly the president's
advisors are telling him he must abandon
that promise Iran is too important they
say it's the greatest threat this
country faces despite the fact that
virtually every terror attack in America
has been inspired not by Iran but by
Iran Sunni enemies doesn't matter the
mullahs are months away from building a
new clean EO khan's tell us keep in mind
these people have been saying the exact
same thing word-for-word for more than a
decade you can look it up on Google they
have no idea what they're talking about
their track records are embarrassing
disaster after disaster they'll be
selling timeshares in Maui or doing
something useful instead they have more
political power than they've ever had
amazingly almost to a person in the same
group bitterly opposed the president
they now work for they repeatedly
attacked him in public and they attacked
him savagely in private they consider
his ideas absurd to this day they regard
the notion of putting America first as
morally offensive they are fully on bill
Crystal's team in fact just last week
crystal was encouraging nikki Haley to
challenge her boss Donald Trump for the
Republican nomination two years from now
in a way that makes sense if there was
ever a swamp in Washington you were
looking at it the foreign policy
establishment they are working overtime
to ensnare the president in a mess in
Iran let's hope that he understands
exactly what's going on Douglas McGregor
is a retired Army colonel author of the
book margin of victory a frequent guest
on the show and he joins us tonight
Colonel Gregor thank you very much for
coming on thanks Tucker I appreciate it
so that I can't help since I've been in
Washington for 30 years notice that the
very people who are pushing this new
entanglement this new enterprise are the
Trump's the Trump administration's great
gravest enemies on almost every subject
and they are also the same people who
predicted outcomes that never came to
pass in other words they've been wrong
again and again and again and again how
do these people still have power well
look I think President Trump lost
control of the whole appointment process
and staffing the government shortly
after the election I don't know the
details but he ended up appointing large
numbers of people who subsequently
brought in their friends almost all of
whom were opposed to Donald Trump in his
agenda
but I think it's important to say
something about the president's comment
because the president's right if you
look at the Iranian defense
establishment we spend more money on one
ford-class aircraft carrier than Iran
spends on its entire military
establishment so if there were a war it
would be a very one-sided affair but the
problem is that Wars don't work that way
they tend to move in directions that no
one anticipated suddenly people that you
would think would otherwise avoid
conflict might decide that it's not in
their interest to see Iran destroyed and
I'm thinking of Russia and I'm thinking
of China has perfect examples why would
they stand by and watch us pulverize
Iran it seems very unlikely so I think
President Trump understands that in fact
this afternoon when he talked to the VFW
he made the comment that he pulled out
of the deal with Iran but he's open to
another deal he's open to talking to
negotiating he's talked to the Russians
and he's talked to the North Koreans
that seems to have had a positive impact
certainly in Northeast Asia we don't
know what will happen in the future but
I think that's a good sign so I think
dealing with Donald Trump understand
that anyone who threatens the United
States with this man in the White House
should seek psychiatric care they're
crazy because Donald Trump means what he
says he will fight to defend the United
States on the other hand I don't see any
evidence that he's interested in
precipitating a conflict do you think
the advisors around him whose comments
we just played nikki Haley for example
or John Bolton I mean they seem to come
at this with pre-existing agendas well
of course but the good news is that
President Trump hasn't listened very
much to his advisors if he did we would
never have made any progress on the
Korean Peninsula we would not be working
with the Chinese we wouldn't we would
never have met with Vladimir Putin so
god bless the president he doesn't
listen to these people so I'm not too
worried about that the thing that does
worry me though given the some of the
comments that have been made is this red
meat on the table for the war lobby you
and I know that there are a lot of
people who would welcome conflict with
Iran that's obvious I think the
president needs to watch carefully for
the potential for something like the
Gulf of Tonkin incident many of your
viewers may not remember that
it never happened and we could very well
be treated to something like that in the
Gulf we should watch for that and this
is an this is an example of President
Trump's comments on fake news he should
not be sabotaged by fake news I I agree
we've seen it happen twice in Syria
twice colonel thank you very much great
to see you